dans le reste de l'actualité
internationale la situation à l'est de
l'Ukraine maintenant elle devient un
célèbre de nietz qui est extrêmement
difficile et le rythme pourrait encore
s'accélérer dans la journée les
autorités ukrainiennes redoutent que
Moscou n'engage aujourd'hui toutes ces
réserves commençant par être cette
localité stratégique les précisions de
notre envoyé spécial à Kiev Pauline
Godard
l'intensité des combats augmente un peu
plus chaque jour les Russes bombardent
sans relâche notamment CV redonnette
l'ennemi utilise l'artillerie à grande
échelle et malheureusement à un avantage
de 10 contre un expliquer le commandant
en chef de l'armée
ukrainienne ils disent quand même malgré
tout que malgré ses tirintants s'ils
arrivent toujours à retenir l'ennemi les
soldats Ukrainiens se battent pour
chaque maître de ses vérodonnettes ça a
expliqué hier le président les élèves
qui lors de son allocution quotidienne
ils sont nombreux à être pour l'instant
retranchés dans l'usine azote à noter
excusez-moi hier que l'armée a fait
sauter un pont qui reliait redonnette à
sa ville jumelle qui se trouve juste en
face licite chance il ne reste donc plus
qu'un pont sur 3 pour faire la liaison
entre ces deux villes les Russes font
tout pour isoler cet endroit et
encercler les quelques les soldats
Ukrainiens qui restent pour le un moment
donc en train de combattre chaque maître
de cette ville de l'Est et puis le fait
également d'avoir détruit ce pont que
donne une possibilité en moi pour les
civils de pourvoir fuir la région
ouais